hi everyone alex gin here so i'm going
to continue with this series of videos
looking at training indoors
and today i'm going to be specifically
focusing on the clubs
and what options we potentially have
in my previous two videos i talk about
training with sword and staff inside
and quite often the problem is the
ceiling height or the surrounding space
i talk about using the wall and how the
wall can actually help you with your
technique
so there's a common problem that i see
with club swingers and that's when
they're performing a circle behind the
head
when they get up into this position
rather than letting the club drop
open the chest out and extend out
what ends up happening is they open the
chest out but they don't let the club
drop they keep it on the same level
and if you have a look there that's
where you'd be hitting the wall side on
you'd see what happens is they do this
type of motion
so the club moves across rather than
dropping down and
circling behind the body and out the
actual motion
it should be here it comes up and behind
the body
and then circles out you can even do a
semi-circle behind your head
in this type of motion as practice so as
you can see here restricted space can
actually help with clean planes and
correct alignment
this can be practiced both with outwards
and inward swings
so to form these swings we need space
either side
but what can we do in even more limited
space using the same idea we can
practice smaller circles rotating from
the wrist
so i can also practice it on the inside
going both forwards
and backwards we could also train these
movements using two clubs
practicing variations using timing and
direction
the clubs could be swung in parallel
from the outside
from the inside and one inside and one
outside
so here i'm showing you the movements
going forwards but the direction can
also be reversed
going backwards using the three same
options
the clubs can also move in the same
direction using split time
this means that they'll be facing away
from each other as they rotate through
the circle
the clubs can also move anti-parallel
meaning they're moving in opposite
directions
with cross points either at the top and
bottom or left and right of the circle
these movements can then all be put
together creating numerous patterns
with various possibilities
i hope you enjoyed this video if you did
please remember to like share and
subscribe
and if you've got any questions leave
them in the comments below in my next
video i plan to look at some similar
concepts but with body movement
anyway until then take care and i'll see
you soon
[Music]